foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
we weren't so my point is we weren't
allowed to tell our story because they
didn't want we've never been lost until
now no matter how hard I tried no matter
how good I was they were still going to
find a way to destroy me being part of
this family it is my duty to uncover
this exploitation and bribery that
happens within our media I'm generally
concerned for the safety of my family I
just really want to get to the other
side of all of this
we just really want to get to the other
side of our list before we're destroyed
because everybody's so horrible to us oh
shut up get your sick buckets ready
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored it's
the nauseating self-serving snows Fest
the whole world is Raging about
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
tonight we'll devote the whole show to
the impact of Harriet and Megan's attack
on the monarchy on the royal family on
Brit we're all a bunch of callous
racists who've wrecked their lives which
is why they're now living in a mansion
in California earning gazillions of
dollars to continue trashing Britain the
royal family and the monarchy I'll talk
exclusively to Megan's half brother
Thomas whose own family were trashed
comprehensively Again by Megan in the
Netflix documentary and there'll be live
reaction from viewers across the UK but
first is my uncensored take and a
warning tonight's show contains spoilers
well Harry and Megan's Netflix series
released to the world this morning is
packed with well not really Revelations
are they sort of rehashed old
Revelations with a new twist as it turns
out we've apparently been wrong all
along Britain is a nasty racist hell
hole where only magnificent Megan stood
up to all this and the world's biggest
victims are not the people of Ukraine or
the people battling covid or people
struggling in a devastating cost of
living crisis no the world's biggest
victims right now are the Duke and
Duchess of Netflix and don't take my
word for him
This Promise of once you're married
don't worry it'll get better
once they get used to you it'll get
better
it of course it'll get better
but truth be told no matter how hard I
try no matter how good I was
no matter what I did
they were still going to find a way
to destroy me
yeah nobody set out to destroy you you
destroyed yourselves in this country
with your ludicrous hypocritical
Behavior the truth be told what she just
said is completely not a garbage Harry
and Megan's romance engagement and
marriage were all good with ecstatic Joy
by the British media the public and the
royal family that they've all now
abandoned that's the truth not Harry and
Megan's truth but the actual truth the
first three hours of this Netflix series
paint a very different far ugly a
picture of this country and our royal
family
eight days after the relationship became
public I put out a statement calling out
the racist undertones of Articles and
headlines that were written by the
British press I wasn't thinking about
how race played a part in any of this I
genuinely didn't think about it some of
the members of family was like right but
my wife had to go through that so why
should your girlfriend be treated any
differently why should you get special
treatment why should she be protected
and I said the difference here is the
race element I sometimes call the
Commonwealth for Empire 2.0 because that
is what it is there is a huge level of
unconscious bias the thing with
unconscious bias is it's actually no
one's fault but once it's been pointed
out or identified within yourself
you then need to make it right
yep we're all racist apparently
sounds like a different country but
let's be clear Britain's one of the most
tolerant and Multicultural nations in
the world we celebrated the Glamorous
modern Flair of neon Royals we eulogize
the newly biracial monarchies the fresh
face of 21st century Britain I wrote
newspaper columns about it myself
including on the day of the wedding the
press and public only turned on Harry
and Megan when their behavior became
obnoxious self-serving and rankedly
hypocritical sadly millions of people
around the world will watch this series
and they'll believe it they'll believe
the smears about Britain and our
monarchy that we're a bunch of bigoted
and hateful people they even blamed
brexit for the racism which apparently
was aimed at Meghan Markle which is just
completely absurd but by far the most
sickening part of this show for me was
the constant use of Harry's late mother
Princess Diana to stoke sympathy for
Megan
so much of what Megan is and how she is
so similar to my mom
she has the same compassion she has the
same empathy she has the same confidence
she has this warmth about her
I accept that there will be people
around the world who fundamentally
disagree with what I've done and how
I've done it
but I knew that I had to do everything I
could to protect my family grandma
nothing says protecting your family like
putting a kids in a reality TV series
does it
having known both women Princess Diana
and Meghan Markle can say with absolute
certainty they're nothing in common
whatsoever I couldn't think of two women
more different when it comes to
compassion and empathy where's Megan's
been for her own father she completely
disowned him as she did all her wedding
actually before the wedding
as the series makes clear
he just suffered a stroke a few months
ago
Miss compassion hasn't even bothered to
call her father to ask how he is and the
answer is we'll find out tonight from
his son Thomas is he's not well at all
Harry's never even met the man whose
daughter he married doesn't care Mr
empathy Mr compassion
yet this man Thomas Markle raised Megan
on his own for many years that wasn't in
the documentary that was glossed over
that was ignored
just like he is now he lives 70 miles
away from them it's about an hour long
cab ride never seen his Grand
grandchildren this show is packed with a
kind of spurious
claims and hypocrisy to become a Sussex
signature we learned they began making
videos about the heroic Journey six
months before their Netflix deal was
even announced and right at the start of
a pandemic it was killing thousands of
people every day their only concern was
their own situation how mean everyone
was being to them not thousands of
people dying in the streets
clearly this is all planned from the
start the show opens with the claim the
royal family declined a comment in fact
they say no one bothered to ask them
because their biggest complaints are as
always about the terrible media
rarely do we have a holiday without
someone with a camera you know jumping
out of a bush or something within the
family within the system the advice
that's always given is don't react there
was always public pressure with its fair
share of
drama
stress
and also tears and witnessing those
tears there's a lot of people who think
they've got such a problem with with
Paparazzi
safety first person in this area we're
going from one garage to another like
it's true
Paparazzi still harass people
it's amazing what people would do when
offered a huge amount of money
to hand over photographs to create a
story right
so we had to flee the country for family
privacies as Harry as we watch a hundred
million dollar documentary when she
flaunts his young children and shares
private text messages intimate
photographs for the entire world to see
when it comes to Paparazzi I have more
Paparazzi outside my house when I was
forced to leave my old job a
disbelieving princess Pinocchio's lies
then I saw actually outside their houses
at any stage of this documentary
maybe their mob scenes are to come we
haven't seen any so far that all their
claims of Paparazzi intrusion in the two
trailers turned out to be nothing to do
with them they weren't even at many of
the events which were depicted
so forgive me if I don't think this is
all a load of BS
but frankly the biggest problem with
this series so far is that like the
Sussex themselves is actually it's dull
it's predictable it's cliche ridden it's
simperingly sycophantic it's one
long-rendition of all their greatest
whinges and a lot of self-congratulatory
nonsense Harry and Megan sold their
Royal souls to become reality TV stars
but they've got the Charisma to carry
their own sob story they're not grasping
ex-royal version of the Kardashians only
with less class less loyalty and less
brains
well in a moment I'll speak to Megan's
half-brother Thomas Jr exclusively
here's a short reminder of what Megan
Harry said about her father in the show
including a series of supposedly private
messages she sent to him when it emerged
he was too ill to attend their wedding
paps and journalist immediately for
following him all day every day the
unraveling happened that week when he
wouldn't pick up my call
and instead you're talking to TMZ he had
a heart attack six days ago which is
crazy calling calling calling calling
this is not him saying oh I don't want
to be there I get it and the world is
watching this drama
of course it's incredibly sad what
happened she had a father before this
and now she doesn't have a father
well joining me now is Megan's
half-brother Thomas Morgan Thomas thank
you for joining me um first of all uh
how is your father Thomas senior
oh hey guys it's good to be here
um dad is doing very well uh making a
lot of progress he's in good spirits
um sometimes he doesn't feel that
comfortable to actually make a live
appearance but uh he's doing very well
you're there caring for him he had a
massive stroke and I think at one stage
for quite a while he lost the power of
his speech has that returned now is he
able to communicate with you
yeah his uh his speeches is definitely
coming back we're making a lot of
progress with the speech therapy and and
you know if for the most part it's it's
pretty normal it just it goes off after
a few moments but comes back so it's
he's doing very well I'm I'm just very
happy that I could be here every day for
him since since this happened in May or
or what about six months ago were you
both watching the the first half of this
series today
uh let's see I think I think he was he
wasn't able to join us though I mean he
really wanted to be here
um I was watching it and you know I'm
just glad I had my studio magic tear pen
with me so I could have a tear come out
of my left eye while I was watching it I
mean that moment when Prince Harry has
never met your father
says that Megan has no father
what did you think of that
I think it's horrible
um the documentary is so far off on so
many different levels so many it's just
it really is really a little bit
disturbing
um
saying that you know she doesn't have a
family and she doesn't have a father and
then Harry's saying that you know she
has no father now that's just ridiculous
yeah I mean it's incredibly hurtful I
also have always had sympathy with your
father because I felt that he was thrown
to the wolves with no experience of
dealing with this kind of media
intensive media attention he tried to do
the right thing he came unstuck and they
just disowned him
um has she made any attempt to contact
your father since he had his stroke
none whatsoever and you know I totally
agree with you on on the fact that none
of us were ever coached or given any
help with the paparazzi or press since
the very beginning which has caused a
lot of problems
um
nobody reached out I actually reached
out and and all I got back was distant
family and she doesn't know us which is
just you know it's just very bizarre
how she just basically brushed the
entire family under the carpet like we
don't exist and then lied about not
having a family and lied about you know
she doesn't have a family that she's
always wanted you know we've always been
here it's
documentaries way off I mean that's
that's what's actually prompted me to
work with my own production team
um and coming out in like 2023 we're
gonna have you know our side of the doc
our side of a documentary that's going
to shed a lot of light well I don't
blame you I mean
this is one of my family doing this to
my family I want to do the same thing
and set the record straight it seems to
me that she's decided you're all too big
a problem therefore you have to be cut
loose and I got to be honest I I knew
Megan for a bit before she met Harry did
exactly the same to me bang you know
done she did that to many people that
she knew that she'd either worked with
or was friends with or whatever it just
seems to me she's what I would call a
ruthless social climber who just when
people are no longer yeah you know no
longer appropriate parts of her Circle
they have to be expunged quickly so she
can move on up a ladder
absolutely and I think a lot of greed
plays into that fact also I mean the
amount of unprecedented files photos
videos and documentation that that we're
going to be including in our documentary
it's going to tell a whole different
story and I think the the I think the
general public and the UK and America
knows
that now the markers aren't bad people
we're we're just like a normal family
like everybody else we do exist and when
when one person tells lies and then
tells 10 other lies to cover the one lie
and it keeps on going you know this is
what happens you you end up looking
ridiculous there's a staggering moment
Thomas where
um Ashley who is I think your niece
who's uh Samantha's daughter uh
befriended Megan and was gonna go to the
wedding and then Megan is apparently
advised by some funky at the palace that
wouldn't be a good idea because
Samantha's not invited so this happens
how do we explain that this half-sister
isn't invited to the wedding but that
the half-sister's daughter is
so
with Ashley the guidance at the time was
to not have her come to our wedding
I think I said I was
hurt on some level but I understood
where it was coming from
to know that it was because of my
biological mother that
this relationship that's so important to
me
was it impacted in that way
[Music]
I feel like because of her was taken
away
has been hard
yeah actually it was because of Megan
that it was taken away Megan could have
had her there as she wanted to have it
instead she wanted to have a bunch of
celebrities she barely knew from the
cloonies to the beckons to Elton John to
James Gordon to Timbuktu I mean he
looked like anyone she'd met on the
party circuit in the previous two years
got the invite but a lot of Harry
friends weren't there and nor was this
niece who she makes a big thing in the
documentary saying we were so close
yeah well I mean there you have it you
know one lie turns into 20 other lies
she didn't have a family so therefore
nobody was invited
I mean
I mean who doesn't invite their family
to a wedding especially a royal wedding
and it's not like it's not like anybody
in my family asked her for one nickel or
anything ever we were all actually like
happy for her when all this happened but
the slow turn of events showed the true
colors of this woman when you when you
finish watching today these first three
episodes what was the kind of overview
about what's happened to to Megan and
Dean what do you think of Harry
well my general overview is I can't
believe
that she was able to be in this position
all by my father's doing by the way
to be in that position and to know what
you're getting yourself into
and then go in there and try and change
a thousand-year-old tradition and
monarchy to to your own liking
who does that
um
it's it's still it's still a big
question I mean my father and I we talk
about it quite a bit it's like I mean
how could you even even consider doing
that you were
everything every woman in their life
could ever dream of you had and you had
to go and make waves and accusations and
be difficult and overall you know taking
Harry away from his family right yeah
I'm afraid I think he's completely
described like I said
um Thomas I gotta leave it there thank
you very much indeed for joining me
please send your father my best weren't
you because I've been concerned about
him
um I'm glad to hear he's he's on the
mend absolutely obviously been a scary
time for you and the family please send
him my very best
absolutely will do thank you so much for
having me all right good to talk to you
which would be nice at the standard uh
Robert Johnson and professor of black
studies at Birmingham University to
Hindi Andrews welcome to both of you
Robert I mean
startling isn't it when you hear her own
half-brother talking that way about this
and how they feel as a family
it's startling It's upsetting I'm sure
for them I mean you know they do seem
when they're on the television to be
fairly normal people right and uh you
know Thomas Markle seniors come in for
an awful lot of criticism for when he
you know allegedly sold out the way he
did but there was no support for him at
the time and I think that he did need
that support how can you call yourself
miscompassion how can Harry say she's so
like Diana who really was full of
compassion and not even contact your
father when he brought you up on his own
for years when he has a massive stroke
well as you said it wasn't even
mentioned that he brought her up on his
own fears in the documentary I thought
the documentary but didn't really
address some of the big issues that were
out there Harry talks about
institutional racism at the at the
palace he doesn't address the fats I
remember I did the story years ago when
he you know he made racist comments
about a a Pakistani he called it a p
word yeah he did and he tape recorded it
and distributed that tape yeah to all
his friends now that actually is not
Harry himself has actually been the
biggest proven racist
is a clear case of it yeah he's accusing
everybody else of oh it's our
unconscious but that wasn't particularly
unconscious but perfectly conscious you
know he he recorded it he did it he
mocked the guy and the guy's father was
Furious okay handy Andrews my problem
with all these racism claims which they
keep spewing is this all generic there
are no specifics there's no meat on the
bone there's no names there's no
incidents there's nothing we can point
to which actually says anyone in the
royal family has been racist to them or
anybody else now without that why should
we believe a word they're saying
well this is what institutional racism
is that the whole point is that you
don't need to have somebody waving a
Nazi flag to be racist it's about the
way she was treated in the Press it's
about the way she was treated by the
family it's about the way she was
restricted in her role it's about her
true color being black and that being
black didn't fit into it what's he gonna
do with her skin I can't imagine again
what
with her skin who are the Royal Family
said anything racist about or two Meghan
Markle we don't know we've not been told
nobody's offense well In fairness then
try In fairness they have actually tried
to defend the family because someone did
raise the color of the baby and they
didn't say who that was we could we
could guess
they're smearing all of them they've
never said who it was but
no but the point is it's not about one
thing so if you look at her media
president look when she that first story
when she came when it came out they were
dating Straight Out of Compton
headline you know otherwise positive
feature which actually was wrong by nine
yeah she came from an area I know okay
Hindi I know L.A I know where Compton is
I know where she was brought up it's
about eight nine miles away the story
was off by eight nine miles exactly the
feature wasn't actually remotely
derogative effects about her
no but Peter you look at they have to
look at the the for example you're
telling that she was a diva she was she
was she was mean to people she was no no
she wasn't she was just acting in a way
that many Royals act but she became seen
as this aggressive black woman she's a
diva that's racism
okay Hindi again I never saw anybody use
her color in the British media as a
stick to attack her ever never saw it it
never happened
nor have I seen any evidence anyone in
the royal family was ever racist to
either of them
so there are a number of people who've
put together comparisons you know
Harry's catering Kate does one thing and
he's treated this way Megan does one
thing you treat a different ways he has
millions of negative headlines he goes
around saying the n-word anymore and
you're saying
really
well I would say well I mean I think
when you have an institution which is
overwhelmingly white which is only a
story she's in it because she's black in
the first place because she wasn't black
we're gonna be talking about all of this
where who then treats her in a way which
is clearly problematic she then leaves
and says look I experience racism and
thought about committing suicide it was
so bad I think we would have to say yeah
well I want to see the evidence of that
too because he said she said a senior
person at Buckingham Palace told her she
couldn't have help for her Suicidal
Thoughts because it would be bad for the
brand of the palace who was that person
and when did that conversation happen
because like a lot of what Meghan Markle
says none of it is borne out by actual
evidence it's just her saying it playing
the race card damaging the market
damaging the raw family royal family
there is lots of evidence of the Royal
Family's press machine is essentially
like the mafia and you can't just say
what you like but like I think yes I
mean this is yes that's not true Mafia
was that's ridiculous you can just say
whatever people who killed people for
fun is that what you're liking the
British the British royal well the real
African can I just can I just point out
the Royal African the Royal African
company was the company which Enslaved
the most people that looked like me in
the history of this planet so actually
yes the Royal Family actually does have
a murderous past and it's a racist
person a deeply Colonial person he is
but if you think they're still murdering
in a superior position they're still
murdering people I think the point how
many people are the royal family
murdered in your lifetime
how many people has the system the Euro
family represent murdered in my lifetime
Millions actually I mean this is the
problem right if you think they're still
doing this benign thing
it probably it
is they're not are they um
the problem with these conversations is
that again there's no substance to it
other than go back in history and say
that hundreds of years ago the colonial
Britain led by the world found me
behaved in a bad way we know that and
they've been apologizing throughout the
last 60 years for it yeah but I mean
this is also about accuracy isn't it and
we this this documentary I I can only
speak as I find there was one particular
moment where I was on a poor position in
South Africa inside the Archbishop
tutu's compound his house and they used
that photograph of them walking away
holding the baby to say it was a lens in
the in the picture to suggest that that
was intrusive by the paparazzi we're
taking the picture here now that's the
narrative that photograph was taken with
three people standing there on the poor
position I was standing next to Sarah
Latham and you know I'll name them Sarah
Latham the press secretary who'd
arranged the position with them and that
was all official and then we went from
there into the into the Archbishop
Archbishop teacher's house where they
had tea and showed the baby again the
Press couldn't show pictures of that
baby under the regulations that we now
have agreed of course the death of Diana
what upsets me about this documentary
about everything else is they've used
all of these things Harry says he can't
remember a lot about his childhood with
Donna apart from the fact that there
were a lot of yeah he's utilizing Diana
the fame of Dinah in this documentation
it's disgusting and he's utilizing that
to get an old narrative across and the
British media has changed enormous by
the way the reason he's doing it is he's
getting 90 million dollars
he's doing the very thing he's accused
the tabloids of doing when his mother
was alive which is using her her image
and everything about her Panorama a
commercial game right exactly Panorama
Robert delivery there thank you very
much handy thank you very much indeed
for joining me coming next Harry and
Megan will Princess Diana's memories as
we just discussed to defend their
actions and claims but does that
comparison have any credibility at all
have guessed between four barrel to
debate that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
really
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
foreign
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
so much of what Megan is and how she is
so similar to my mom
she has the same compassion she has the
same empathy she has the same confidence
she has this warmth about her
well
joining me now are royal correspondent
for Vanity Fair Katie nickel Princess
Diana's former Butler Paul Bowen
historian and Orthodox well Paul you and
I I had lunch with Princess Diana and a
Young Prince William was 13. at
Buckingham Palace uh because of the
palace I'm sorry you were the butler
serves a very nice meal I have to say uh
two hours of donor and she was
completely Charming compassionate
empathetic and all those things I also
need Meghan Markle who in my estimation
from everything that happened before
during and after when I knew her is a
complete piece of work devoid of any
real compassion witness her father and
the family
devoid of empathy uh who's taken this
Prince away from his family now and is
trying to exploit the Royal titles for
maximum gain that is not what Dinah did
no she never was in it it's a personal
game not a penny when you heard Harry
say that is he lost his mind I'm I I I'm
gobsmacked
you cannot compare Princess Diana to
Megan they are two totally different
creatures in totally different spaces at
totally different times and if you had
lived with her for 10 years as I did I
can honestly say there is no comparison
Princess Diana test none Paul I mean
Harry is a man in love he's in love with
Megan and his memory of Diana is one she
was a 10 and 11 year old boy yes is he
in love or is he as Donald Trump told me
have we got the Donald Trump clip oh do
we have to play the Donald Trump clip
yeah
have we got it this is what Donald Trump
said it wasn't really love he thought
was a problem let's listen to this
here we go it's coming it's the magic of
live television
Harry is whipped do you know the
expression I'm familiar I won't use the
full expression and Harry is whipped
like no person I've ever seen the most
weak man in the world this is I don't
know that's going to be a big one but he
is he is a whipped man yeah yeah the
full expression is he's [ __ ] whipped I
don't want to take my advice on romance
and love from two Neanderthal men over
50. quite frankly I think you're all
missing the point I thought the main
takeaway message which you could learn
from and all three of us could probably
be humiliated by was the relationship
the crony relationship between the
British press and the palace there's
Mutual dependence which was massively
sorry no it's corrupting I must have
been thriving as a former tabloid
newspaper editor for 10 years yes I know
more about that relationship than you do
with it historically I probably actually
than you do because I was on the
shopping the idea that somehow there was
something delusion collusion between the
newspapers and the journalists
sorry having covered the rules for the
best part of 15 years let me just tell
you and it one of the things that
annoyed me so much in what Harry said
was the idea that we are just a royal
rotor that had just drip fed material
from the house if only it was that easy
his contempt for the bridge
by the way what about this this is a guy
whining about the media what she's
what's he done since he's left Royal
duties he's now on James corden's bus
stop he's doing Oprah Winfrey he's doing
a Netflix reality show the guy never
stays off of using the media doing it
all he wanted was cash and what we need
to be honest about is the conservative
predominantly conservative press rely on
access to the royal family for their
Scoops for their biographies even eyes
historian oh if I go too far will I get
into the Royal archive the truth is it's
compromising and if we're all done our
job properly maybe there would be a
royal truth is which has the truth is
the truth is Harry has always attacked
tabloids including ones that I used to
edit for exploiting the royal family for
commercial gain now he is exploiting his
hatred of the royal family for
commercial game even using his own
mother the late Princess Diana to do
that for money for hard dollars
and it is disgusting hypocrisy his
mother his mother would be very unhappy
she'd be furious about what was
happening now because it upsets William
it upsets Kate and those boys had a pact
that these interviews would not be shown
again on National Intelligence
let me bring in we've got a stellar
panel of ordinary members of the public
here all of whom have strong opinions we
won't get to all of you and you know
that but I got a Fran Foley Winston
who's in Dublin Fran what was your take
on what we saw today
but it was just so cringe-worthy I don't
know how to manage that sixth episode it
was halfway through and the words even
engaged yes you know I don't think their
days are that long in real life
ridiculous
so you weren't impressed
no and I'm actually I've been a group of
Massachusetts coming up right we're
having a problem with your with your
link now I'm gonna try and come back to
you a bit later but let's go now to uh
we're gonna get a Nicola Myers what is
your view of a different view I think
Nicola
um okay so my view of the Netflix series
as it happens this morning I've actually
watched episode one two and three back
to back
um and I loved it okay I absolutely
loved it before I watched it I wasn't
sure of my opinion of everything that
had gone on with Megan and Harry and if
they were set out to jeopardize their
British Monarchy
um after watching it I I'm on their side
I'm for Megan and Harry why they
absolutely am why the Madeline little
the Madeline I'm very happy why trash
their families
yeah
why trash the families I don't think
they've purposely set out two trash
there they've literally purposely shut
up
Harry has got scared of all the
um racial abuse
um that the love of his life was getting
he saw it happening what had happened to
his mother where his mother got murdered
and and he's he's panicked of God
okay all right let me go to magali gore
who's in uh
oh we haven't got my guardian I'm sorry
we'll come back to we'll come back to
another one of our panel in a moment I
mean it's interesting isn't it lots of
different reactions I've heard some
people say they like them and they
support them you see that on social
media a lot I gotta say walking around
today I didn't meet anyone in Kensington
on the streets it was anything but
Furious yes I've not had anyone on my
Twitter feed coming in saying saying
that at all and people saying we're
going to cancel our Netflix subscription
there seems to be a real reaction
exploitation of Princess Diana's image
it's very anti-british I'm going to own
that that really struck me this morning
in my little British home I thought gosh
I felt almost like I was under siege and
I'm fairly neutral in terms of you know
where my affections lie whether it's for
the Royals I was watching with my wife
silly it's her birthday today happy
birthday to my wife um and we couldn't
think of a better way to enjoy her
birthday than to spend three hours
watching those whining little brats in
Montecito but we sat and watched it and
about halfway through we touched it away
this is really boring and the reason it
was boring was because they were
repeating so much of the rehash stuff
which we heard on Oprah it's like it's
the same it's like Elvis playing all his
oldies I'm quite as good that's not
appealing to you the voyeuristically
let's have a look in them on to sit at
home oh they met on Instagram all those
aspects to be fair peers I mean it's
going to the generation below even me
let alone usually well let's go let's go
all right we can go to magali gore now
is Gore I'm sorry magali Gora who's in
Cheshire my God I think you can hear me
now what's your view
yes hi hi well to be fair I I I have
double feelings about it but one feeling
that I can say is that as you can see
I'm a woman I'm Brown and when I saw
royalty getting in love and she was a
brown
princess because she became a princess
uh the door went over for so many dreams
of little girls like me when I was young
and I was raised in a very white
Community uh racist racist now sometimes
people are not uh used to how you look
like they're not used to how you
um what your roots are or what your
background is or that you handle things
maybe differently
um I loved the wedding for example the
wedding was this American uh well I
agree with you I wrote all that I wrote
all this uh magali I wrote a big piece
for the okay on Sunday saying exactly
what you've just been saying I think
that was the General mood of this
country that's why I'm so angry that
they're now trying to make out they were
driven up by races Britain races Royals
racist media none of that was true now
what what did you think now having
watched it today what's your view of
them now
um it is a repeat on a lot of things and
I have to be honest to you
still we cannot really feel what she
felt I only know that when you're coming
in an institution that's where she comes
in in a family that is a very strong a
very serious family a very you know look
at the queen she is born to do this you
know so this is what you do this is what
you're gonna live and then it comes a
girl from America that thinks with the
American background to the red carpets
oh I'm gonna make it now look at me no
no no no no you have to live like the
protocols yeah and I think that's a
struggle and okay
I'm gonna leave it there I'm gonna take
a break but thank you for that I'm going
to come back after the break and we'll
talk more about this I think we also
Meghan Markle mocking the moment she met
the queen and had to courtesy and
Harry's response
does it get any more disrespectful than
that
we'll talk about it after break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
tonight we're on here in five minutes
yeah I'm just getting rid of some stress
it's fine
you've got someone at guitar for me okay
you're definitely out there right yeah
yeah I'm out here I need some a-listers
on the show yeah we're just getting 5000
quick
Stadium
but I can't speak Portuguese I probably
have to get a beer out here I can
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
there's no class in some person who goes
sit like this cross your legs like this
use this Fork don't do this curtsy then
wear this kind of hat it doesn't happen
and I remember in the car and driving up
and he's you know how to curtsy right
and I just thought it was a joke I mean
Americans will understand this we have
Medieval Times dinner and tournament it
was like that like I curtsied as though
I was like
[Music]
laughs
pleasure to meet you your majesty
yeah nice right mocking Our Queen
mocking uh the fact she had to show her
respect by just learning other courtesy
prophecy it's not hard to learn is it if
you're marrying into the family well
joining me now is the editor of
Hollywood unlocked Jason Lee Nissan
Martin Luther King Jr alvida King and
conservative radio host Ben folks and I
still have uh Paul and Katie with me so
um
let me start with you if I may Ben
Ferguson what does America make of this
I mean surely they're not falling for
this are they
yeah can you please come get your
Kardashians that's number one number two
uh it seems like these two individuals
that are obsessed with being private
people and being out of the public eye
are actually a bunch of narcissists that
are totally obsessed so being in the
public eye it was a crybaby special I
mean I at full disclosure I could only
watch so much of it peers before I said
give me a break roll my eyes and moved
on with my life so I would say if you
want to waste three hours of your life
and you love drama and your soap opera
isn't coming in watch this because it's
amazing yeah but this rewriting of of
History through their eyes like there's
some somehow victims they're not victims
she's crazy and she's trying to destroy
a family here and I and I I used to kind
of feel sorry for Harry I don't anymore
because he's sitting there doing it with
her like you can even see at the curtsy
moment that you just came in with here
he looks at her almost like she's crazy
and maybe in three or four or five years
she'll realize yeah
I think that's the moment we'll look
back on I suspect in a couple of years
and that'll be a Tipping Point let's go
to Velveeta King I want to think Dr King
is one of my all-time Heroes as he is
many people he truly was somebody who
stood up to racial Injustice racial
inequality like nobody in modern times
uh and it cost him his life the idea
that these two are in any way on any
level
people doing similar stuff is to be
fanciful they're just sitting there in a
mansion in California spray gunning
their families uh calling them a bunch
of callous vile races without any
evidence aren't they
um do I just jump in well yes
off
you go can you hear me I can hear you
yeah can you hear me okay all right well
here I am I grew up with the Princess
and the Pea Cinderella lately wakanda
forever and exploring all these various
cultures and so there is no happily ever
after in Cinderella land if you're from
two different cultures and so what we
have is a cultural confusion on Megan's
part and she wants to superimpose her
culture on her husband and their family
and that just doesn't work but I'm
remindful of my uncle Reverend Dr Martin
Luther King Jr we must learn to live
together as brothers and I'll say as
sisters or perish together as fools now
there's only one blood and one human
race and so to put racism into
everything doesn't necessarily ring true
either and really Britain had a queen I
think it was Prince Queen Sophie who was
part German and part black African
African person so it's not like the
monarchy is supposed to skin color but
there's only one blood in One race but I
think Megan is mixing Maybe
Hollywood fantasy and her pain of what
she wants to see but you can't topple a
whole line of traditions based on pain
but past pain there is communication it
takes some guts to even speak out and
say some of these things but we want to
bring this back into a reality and I
think that's the problem Avida that's
one of the most brilliant analysis I've
heard actually of the whole faraga thank
you absolutely brilliant
um I want to bring in Jason Lee now you
you fall for all this you think they're
great Heroes and deserve all the awards
they're getting and their freedom
fighters standing up to the oppressive
Brits dude
well I'm not obsessed with them to the
point that I'm following every move that
they're making but I have watched the
documentary and so far I I love it and
I'm somebody who's black and white and
you know I've listened to some of the
people on the show today the guy who
started at the top of this segment has
just annoyed me you can tell he probably
doesn't have much love in his life and
the woman before the last segment she
was probably a bit oversized and
unattractive
doesn't really sound like she had hold
on wait we already heard what you had to
say clearly you're mad that there's
black blood in the bloodline for the
royal family but since you want to talk
about if you want to talk about racism
in the UK let's talk about the racism in
UK then because the blood diamonds at
Buckingham Palace have not been returned
you're very consumed with the man who's
in love with a black woman that's the
problem that you have but this is the
deal
wait a minute wait a minute
here's the deal everybody got to talk
before all right everybody got to talk
at once Jason here's the problem Jason
it's when you get to the specifics of
who in the royal family has actually
been racist there's no answer there's no
evidence there are no facts it's all
just smear by association they're racist
they're blind to it all they're
unconsciously biased blah blah blah
where where is the meat on the bone
where are the facts
well we haven't seen it all yet and I
think that we have to let them tell
their story right we're both in the
media one thing I love about you pierce
you say what you feel what you think
regardless of how people feel and I
think they should be given the same
Freedom we enjoy talking about them let
them tell their story so we could talk
about their story I I look at their Love
Story from their point of view and I
look at how it's been reported and I can
enjoy it all without feeling you know
getting in my feelings I think that how
she described meeting the queen I don't
know how I would have felt if I would
have met the queen I didn't have that
privilege but I probably would have been
nervous too and I don't know what
preparation went on I mean what we're
looking at is very public people who are
under scrutiny who had private lives and
now we're seeing what that lives
she made the queen privately and she was
with the Queen's grandson who probably
does know how you greet the queen
exactly exactly
I want to thank Jason
I think you would like to just verify
Ben just to clarify you do have love in
your life yeah yes yes I have a life
that loves me three children
that likes my panel thank you very much
verdicts here from Teddy and Paul
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
tonight we're on in five minutes yeah
I'm just getting rid of some stress fun
samanthritis you've got something at the
top of me okay you're definitely out
there right yeah yeah I'm out here I
need some a-listers on the show oh we're
just getting 5000 quick
stadium
and go back into football but I can't
speak Portuguese I probably have to get
a beer out here I can
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my brother-in-law used to be the person
in charge of training William and
Harriet Sandhurst military academies all
the Royals need to go down there
printing for their passing out bracelet
I thought you want to know that I've
seen the royal family in action in
private after the passing outbreaks
they're the most loving affectionate
relaxed people just like any other
normal family we watch them all hug each
other tease each other it was lovely to
be a part of I witnessed it at both
Harry and Williams passing out Bros
Megan is talking absolute bleep thank
you Charlotte my sister
um we're all pretty much the same with
my family uncensored and we go to
samsara quickly in Canterbury very
quickly Sam Sarah your view
my view is it's fascinating just like
you said it's a big statement that says
nothing's wrong with me nothing's wrong
with us we're normal people we've had an
experience and the thing that Harry
talks about is unconscious bias so I
know you've mentioned racism and perhaps
it's not being called out just yet
explicitly in the documentary but it's
the blind spots it's the areas where
people might well be well-meaning but in
fact underlying that are some prejudices
and judgments
okay that's a good point uh Katie your
overview really from all the discussions
we've had I mean we haven't mentioned
yet the little digs that were going on
about Kate and William yeah the other
people you know fitting the mold wires
well he said you know the men in the
family married women who fit the mold
well I think you can look at William and
Kate in their 10-year love story before
they even married and say this is one of
the most enduring love stories of
overall history and respectful of the
institution which gives them a luxurious
life they have but apparently you know
the they were called towards you know
the couple and there was that because
when Meghan Markle which was the first
time she's Barefoot Monster Hunter ball
he's like she's a 36 year old divorcee
yes I'll probably give her a bit of a
wide birth myself yeah Paul remember
respect don't trash the royal family we
love them here in England they're our
institution remember what your mother
would say to you your mother would say
to you Harry I'm proud of you for being
a member of our royal family I'm proud
of your brother I always thought that
you'd be his wingman and she was very
proud to be a princess I've got letters
at home I want to absolutely hate the
rift with William absolutely and the
fact that they would go on national
television now for the second time and
trash William and Kate and Charles and
all of it it's just it would be and I
could say Harry is monopolized Diana and
her Legacy and can you imagine how that
must feel for the Prince of Wales yes
she was both of their mother and he is
and by the way they've just lost the
queen right they're all still grieving
the loss of our greatest motto thank you
both very much come back next week for
part two that's it for me whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored good
night
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
tonight we're on here in five minutes
yeah I'm just getting with some stress
it's fine same amount of dice you've got
someone at guitar for me no you're
definitely out there right yeah yeah I'm
out here I need some a-listers on the
show Howard's getting five thousand
quickly
Stadium
but I can't speak Portuguese
out here I can great okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you